Speaker 1: I'm going to give you the headline
and tell you it really shouldn't be a headline,
and that's really what we're going to be focusing
in on. Three Republicans will be voting for Joe
Biden's Supreme Court nominee, Judge Katamari
Brown Jackson. Wow. And it has made dozens and
dozens of headlines, and yet it really shouldn't
even be a headline. The reason that this is a
headline is because Supreme Court confirmations
have become so brazenly Partizan that it actually
makes news when just a few Republicans are able to
say, Wait a second in the Senate, we're supposed
to determine is this a qualified individual
to be on the court? And if he or she is,
then we should vote to confirm it seems quaint. It
seems almost antiquated. It seems sort of like the
the way of the past, because mostly it is. And we
have seen hyperpartisan word salad explanations as
to why many Republicans are not going to be voting
to confirm Judge Jackson. So The Associated Press
reporting Murkowski, Romney back Jackson all but
assure confirmation. We already know about Maine
Republican Senator Susan Collins, who said she
would be voting for Judge Jackson's confirmation.
And it just makes perfect sense. The Associated
Press reporting Republican Senators Lisa Murkowski
and Mitt Romney announced they will vote
to confirm Judge Katon G. Brown Jackson
giving President Joe Biden's nominee a burst of
bipartisan support and all but assuring she'll
become the first black female justice. Republican
Susan Collins announced last week she would back
Jackson, noting her stellar qualifications. All
three Republicans said they did not expect to
agree with all of Judge Jackson's decisions, but
they found her extremely well-qualified Romneys.
Romney said Jackson more than meets the standard
of intelligence of excellence and integrity.
Murkowski said she will bring it to the Supreme
Court, a range of experience from the courtroom
that few can match given her background in
litigation. So she is going to be confirmed
and she should be confirmed because the truth is
she is arguably as qualified as any of the nine
justices currently on the court. I've referred
to this document before that was put together,
which looks at the experience and qualifications
of the nine justices currently on the court,
as well as Judge Jackson's. And as you can see,
Judge Jackson, if you're if you're looking. Judge
Jackson is the only the only of the what we're
talking about 10 people, the nine on the court,
plus her who has this wide range of experience.
She has public high school education, which
you can argue gives a particular perspective
that is useful for a justice to have.
She has the Ivy League law school education
as well. She was a Supreme Court clerk. She is
the only of the nine plus one justices and judge
to be a public defender. She is the only other
than Judge Sotomayor to have been a district
judge. She's the only one other than Judge
Breyer to have been on a sentencing commission and
of course, serving as well on as a judge on the
Court of Appeals. And what's both funny and kind
of disheartening to see is that many Republicans
don't even really seem to know why they aren't
voting for her confirmation, or at least they're
not willing to say it. And maybe that's the
more important thing. Earlier this week,
I played a clip for you of Republican Senator
Roy Blunt. He was asked by George Stephanopoulos,
Are you going to support her? And he said, No,
I'm not. And when he was asked why he went on
like a 90 second word salad that didn't make any
sense, something about judicial philosophy that
was completely unintelligible. We have other
examples of this. Here is Lindsey Graham
recently saying he is not going to be voting to
confirm Judge Jackson, but she's very qualified
and smart and seems to meet all the requirements.
Speaker 2: Judge Jackson has got a lot to be proud
of. She's accomplished a lot in her life. She's
a good person. I'm sure she's a great mother and
a very gifted person. She's fought hard to
be where she's at in life. I'll vote. No,
I'm the first first time I've ever
voted against any Supreme Court nominee.
Speaker 1: Here's another example
of Lindsey Graham as well.
Speaker 2: I find Judge Jackson's to be
a person of exceptionally good character.
Respected by our peers and someone who has
worked hard to achieve her current position.
However, her record is overwhelming in its lack
of a steady judicial philosophy and a tendency to
achieve outcomes in spite of what the law requires
or common sense would dictate. After a thorough
review of Judge Jackson's record and information
gained at the hearing from an evasive witness,
I now know why Judge Jackson was the favorite
of the radical left, and I will vote no.
Speaker 1: So it's basically a meaningless
statement. Her judicial philosophy is. Steady in
its record. Now some of you have been writing to
me saying, David, you know why they're not voting
for her? But they can't say it. They're not voting
for her because she's black. Now, I don't have
evidence that that's the case. What it does seem
to me is that her identity, meaning a black woman
nominated by a Democrat named Katanga.
Those characteristics are making Republicans
look at her record in a different way than they
would if this was someone nominated by Donald
Trump with a different identity. And you don't
have to look much further than, for example,
Lindsey Lindsey, Graham's vote in favor of
her being appointed to the Court of Appeals,
where she currently sits. Lindsey Graham is
not the only Republican who has said many
times what we do. She's very qualified for other
positions, and when they're asked about this,
what you'll often hear from them is they'll say,
Well, it's a different standard now because this
is the highest court of the land. Someone that
would be qualified for a lower court wouldn't
necessarily be qualified for the highest court
in the land. That's totally plausible. It's at
least theoretically an acceptable differentiation.
They just aren't able to articulate exactly what
they mean, and it's very transparently pathetic.
Now, one other note on Mitt Romney supporting her
Mitt Romney is a less crazy Republican. There's
no doubt of that. Not saying I love Romney,
not saying I want Romney to be the president of
the United States. But Mitt Romney is a far less
crazy Republican than many of these other people
at the same time. We shouldn't ignore the idea
that maybe Romney is trying to just kind
of revive the May the possibility that he
could run for president in the future, although
I still don't think that he has plans to do that,
he said before. It's not something he intends to
get back in, but maybe Mitt Romney for that or
other reasons wants to kind of rehabilitate his
reputation. I don't know. Now, in the meantime,
the cuckoo for cocoa puffs or the what would we
call anyway, the wacky wing of the Trump wing
of the Republican Party? They are coming up with
wild attacks on the three Republicans that will
be supporting Judge Jackson, including Marjorie
Taylor Greene, tweeting Murkowski, Collins and
Romney are pro pedophile because they plan to
support Judge Catanese Brown Jackson. That's
obviously an absurd interpretation. The question
is, is she qualified? The answer is yes, she is.
The outcome? If you put these inputs into a
computer and you calculate the outcome should
be. We're going to vote to confirm her. And so
far, we know about three Republicans that will